So, guys i'm gonna get straight into it, obviously
there's this tweet that's going around, and obviously i need to clarify certain things. I can
tell you exactly what happened to the accident you know
with that female, you know, I was feeling a bit depressed that day, you know, it was a bit lonely
It was hard times for me, it was hard times for me... I wasn't married then, you know, as human beings, you know
we all have needs so, you know. You know, i just, you know, i just i just slipped up
Are you dizzy!?
Do you think i'm poor bowden gonna go sexually harass people. Now want to make something REALLY CLEAR and I want  you guys to understand, because
These moves that's been happening recently and hope you guys know, this tweet that, was tweeted from a
Weird lady this whoever "muslimah" that she is called
Her page she opened her flippin page in november. she's got five flippin pictures, yeah and you know
What's funny, tommy robinson tweeted this right now i want to say thank to you guys
Tommy robinson is literally in fear, let me tell you guys, why, yeah recently since this, whole poor golding, this...
...Britain first thing happened -- how, I went there, you know...
...how, she was acting militant, you know, being violent with me, etcetera, didn't allow...
...me to speak then i went again, to the police station as you can...
...see, here, she starts crying and getting all dramatic
And that and this dah.. after that happened i send out the tommy robinson yeah and he knows, what's happening he knows
His time is up -- intellectually is finished for him. You know
Because he knows that as a muslim youtuber, an orthodox one who follows the quran and the sunnah to the tee, everything
Yeah, he's not ashamed of his religion, who is not apologetic i'm not here to sugarcoat my religion
And by the way this is habibi (a friend), yeah so it doesn't say jihad, no it doesn't say go kill anyone
No, no calm down, yeah
You know, what's really crucial guys please look at this carefully -- How is it that tommy robinson...?
...ends up finding these, new, accounts i'm only, new...
...accounts that comes across them, yeah I wouldn't be surprised if he makes them himself yeah, i just want to know something there -- How...
...does Tommy Robinson come across these weird tweets
like, how? It's not gonna pop up in this news, because he's
not following the person, yeah? So -- and it's a new account, it's from November -- so how, does Tommy Robinson find this tweet...
"randomly"
Retweet it without nobody even tagging him say, oh look AliBawah apparently
Asked the size of a the bra of a woman, and tried to sexually, assault, her i'm the poor goulding, sorry Alhamdulillah I'm married so how
Does he come across this
Unless he is the one who got somebody to make that account or he himself has made that account for him to be aware of
that tweet yeah and he retweets it. Now look at the desperation guys two days ago he
Was talking, about the video that i did about the sister who, was?
Twerking and it was video done and he's even trying to twist that to say you made him cry
Just, like how, maginot, was tried. By backfired on it didn't work it because that sister's family got in contact with me
Twerking and i did an interview, with her and a family thanked
Me for stopping the bullying and trying to get those videos down, because the sister was distressed yeah okay, and he's not?
Ohh look at you muslims having a big do for a girl twerking, excuse me excuse, me, we have our beliefs yeah nobody says bully her
What she did was wrong if you go to the orthodox community here, I dare you yeah you know the ones you know
Zionist fond hyou and i dare you to go to the othodox community here and see a jewish girl twerking and let's see
What the jewish community does ofcourse there is going to be outraged of course they are, why, is speaking just about muslims, why
Don't you go to this hurry
Hurry, to community in stamford ooh yeah and do the same with them you go and question them, you wouldn't. You can see the desperation
When somebody's scared or when somebody's cornered, what, did they do?
Do, what did they do when they can't address
Your points and your issue what did they do, they start personally attacking you, at hominins, yeah they start saying you're like
This look at you you know look at your your face look at
Your, nose look at you can see when they can't address your issue and they know
Tommy robinson knows it's night night for him it is jen as a time you know denies a lot but
Janazah (funeral for his argument), yeah that means Allah is great, by the way calm down, yeah
It's janazah, janazah means it's your intellectual funeral funeral, janazah means funeral yeah
Tommy i'm telling you mate i will come wherever you like
lunch on me halal yeah if you, want you can have your bacon and I will have
My, halal chicken or I be vegetarian these days
Anytime anyplace i dare you, lets have a debate, let's have a discussion using your friends book
Which i'm gonna debunk. Can you believe I was reading this
friends book here called, my muslim to kill for islam yeah
muhammad's quran, and
I've got pdf, oh, by, the way, no way i'm paying for that hell, no especially with the reviews i'm gonna show
You, some of the reviews. Yeah you would laugh your head off you will laugh, look at these reviews here
and
I Couldn't believe it the nonsence that's on it yeah i've got muslim saved for when i meet tommy but, this specially
Want if you read the quran chronologically in invoice chances if you read it in front of front about
Back to front backwards you see that islam is promoting killing i didn't know if i should laugh or cry
At that statement i go for a little break to dubai
Literally, absolute joke, so what i'm gonna do is guys as you, guys know
This tweet is fake you know it's, big yeah i'm gonna come and sexually assoult you in public
Asked for your, bra size, who the hell, asked... oh Hey Hi madam
Here just wanted to know. Please forgive me yeah just and by the way aggressively yeah, and what's your bra size?
Tell me the bra size now, i want to know it turns me on tell me your, bra size, what
Was that what the hell are you talking about here
Like i said before guys
This is nonsense rubbish as you, guys know i'm not doing this video for clarification i'm doing this video to show
Tommy robinson is shook he is scared this is an official challenge i dare you to debate me on
This, topic that Islam promotes terror i dare and challenge you i challenge you, yeah we're
Gonna, use your friends book i tell
You, mimi i've been asking for a long time you avoiding, me you, don't you, you
Don't meet me this is an invite let's have a debate lets have a discussion
If not tommy i will track you down i will find you
And when i find you In shaa Allah, with the permission of Allah I'm going to embarrass you with your own friends, book he's got your
Name on it yeah your friend book, all you have done is copy
And paste in the quran got your friend to write a few things, yeah, which i saw, was an sbsolute comedy a
Joke, and you just put a name on it that's all you've done if that means you're writing, books
Fam i'm telling you i'm going to publish all kind of books you know get people to write a
Copy, paste and put my name on it your, fans and people that watch, my, stuff they
Want to see this discussion happened take a, good look at this face me because you In Shaa Allah with the permission of allah subhana
Wa ta'ala, yeah the all merciful the most mighty, yeah the one that we worship yeah i would eventually meet you?
For a discussion and i will challenge you in all your points, yeah save yourself embarrassment
And let's do this if not i'll see you soon mate goodbye salaam alaikum
What's your bra size?